it is a cult thinking about it it's a
cult
that's simply based around money at
first
everything seems okay everything is
welcoming
the way they did it they don't tell you
what it is they just said come to an
event
and i think i just turned 15 at the time
i got more people out
pushing something than selling it it's
confusing to me
what is a pyramid what is if that's not
a pyramid
what's a pyramid lovely when you do that
all right when the opportunity is
presented to you
when you're told that your dreams can be
achieved faster than you think
is only a mindset that wealth
is not as far off as you think it is
that financial freedom
is yours for the taking when these
things are dangled in front of you like
a carrot on a stick
when it sounds too good to be true but
believing otherwise means losing hope
why would you refuse this little black
box that says unique across it
changed my life and i would love to kind
of share this business opportunity
and i'm here to share with you the
moonskin business opportunity
over the next few minutes i'm going to
share a way for you to make money from
home to a passionate
purpose-built set your family free
financially
i would pay hundreds of dollars to join
a business like this
we have a million dollar opportunity
the wildest dreams you've ever thought
of can come true
in herbal life multi-level marketing
companies have been around for a long
while now
and if you're not familiar with what
multi-level marketing is then perhaps
you're familiar with the companies that
follow the multi-level marketing model
these are companies that are valued in
the billions international in their
reach
it sounds just fine doesn't it on the
surface it seems ordinary something you
may never take a second glance at but
once you go beyond the surface level and
uncover what's underneath
it's a huge business it's also created a
huge controversy a strategy where they
decided to target
the poorest people in the world they
indoctrinate you with so
much self-help they are predatory
however the people most likely to be
preyed upon are already
vulnerable you tell the people you love
they're in a pyramid scheme and they go
no i'm not you're just a hater well hold
on
that business structure sounds familiar
isn't that a pyramid scheme
again i ask you if it sounds too good to
be true but believing otherwise means
losing hope
why wouldn't you refuse it's important
that you pay close attention now
because when a pyramid scheme or a cult
is presented to you
it will not reveal itself as such it
will come wrapped in a well-decorated
packaging with a pretty bow on the top
disguised as a million dollar
opportunity
disguised as a way to work when you like
set your family
free financially when it presents itself
to you it will not come dressed in the
robes of an unfamiliar character
it will come dressed as your best friend
your neighbor someone you admire someone
you love
its message will be that of hope and
that of all you've ever wanted
it will come disguised as anything and
everything but that of which it actually
is
[Music]
consider the next two parts of this
video a simulation for a common
collective
experience for many who enter well-known
mlm companies
there are nuances to them all but the
overarching story remains relatively the
same
we'll discuss the details later and just
how reflective this model is of the
industry as a whole
but for now sit back and brace
yourselves
this is the pitch
it's a message the platform in which
it's sent on doesn't matter
but it's an old friend a family member
someone you know they've just reached
out asking how things are going with you
it seems harmless on the surface maybe a
little strange
but you respond you start talking then
they mention
it a business opportunity and that they
thought you'd be a good fit for it they
explained that they've been working for
a company recently
and this company is changing lives
changed their lives
again you'd be perfect for it they tell
you phrases like
six to seven figure earners financial
freedom be your own boss
seem to float around effortlessly in
their sentences it sounds great but
there's still that feeling
something that's not quite right they
invite you to a seminar or an event of
some sort
you decide to go you arrive at the event
and suddenly you're engulfed with
positive energy
people are smiling cheering jumping up
and down the opportunity has them
excited
a speaker comes to the stage mouthing
off words of motivation
everything in this business is mindset
stating how the company is impacting
lives
in four short months my life has changed
quite a bit as it is the number one
thing that changed my life
those phrases appear again financial
freedom six to seven figure earners be
your own boss
passive income here you create your own
income you can be 16 to make as much
money as you want you can be 85 make as
much money as you want
then you're finally told that the
company that's changed everything for
them
is the company that sells nutritional
supplements clothes
essential oils skin care financial
products makeup
perfume the list goes on but the
principles remain
they have a product but the only people
allowed to sell this product
are their distributors their consultants
their coaches
and whenever you sell you earn a
commission last year he was 25 years old
making 10
000 a week with no college degree
you tell them that you'll think about it
and although something feels off
you can't help but feel tempted you
browse through the social media pages of
the friend that got you into this in the
first place
motivational quotes a happy lifestyle a
car given to them by the company they're
working from home
those phrases appear again financial
freedom be your own boss
work from home they're enticing concepts
why
there's hope in this opportunity you
call back your friend
you reach out to them or perhaps they've
asked if you've decided yet and although
something doesn't feel quite right
the promise of a greater life has
enticed you enough you agree to join
and the great thing about the
opportunity it doesn't care
who you are it doesn't make any
difference what your background is
it doesn't make any difference what
color skin you got doesn't make any
difference what religion you are it
doesn't make any difference what kind of
a place you are
it starts by purchasing a starter kit or
a monthly membership
fee this is important you're told for
your business to thrive you need to
invest in it
[Music]
to buy a starter kit with it works it
costs 99
you're told that you must become a
product of the product and you're
encouraged to purchase as much stock as
you can
that's what it means to invest in your
business you're using your young living
products
every single day incorporating them into
your lifestyle on a daily basis
you're shown a list of tiers in the
company and as your sales increase you
are granted
points that allow you to progress
through each tier and with each tier
you're given bonuses from the company
in lularoe the ranks are trainer
and then coach and then mentor the
friend that recruited you into this
opportunity is now labeled as your
upline
your manager so to speak they encourage
you to start posting about the company
and his product on social media to start
talking about it as much as possible to
your friends your family the people you
meet every day but the products are
overpriced
compared to other products on the market
these shakes these clothes this makeup
it seems far too expensive
but before you can even start worrying
about that you're cool to attend another
weekly seminar meeting or some form of
get together with other distributors of
the product
the usual motivational speak begins
success is not a matter of doing it is a
matter of being
let's talk about your mindset you're
told that the opportunity can make you
so much money you know next month i'm on
track to hit ambassador
which is by the numbers yeah it's a
quarter million a year that it's
possible but only if you work
really hard at it you cannot expect to
have massive success
if this is something you do in between
the other stuff that you're focused on
you're told that you have to stay
positive the negative people will get in
your way but you must rise above it and
stay positive no matter what can you
expect
to learn at a rapid pace if you're
surrounded by people who are constantly
trying to pull you down
you're given some self-help material to
read as homework then something else
happens
you're told that if you want to make
good money in this business you'll have
to start recruiting the action phones
behind this business
is in recruiting so that's bringing
people into the business
that is where the big money comes from
it's simple you recruit someone else
into the company and when they make a
sale you'll get a commission for it
do the maths if you have just five
people working under you and they each
earn you five hundred dollars in
commission and they each recruit five
people that will get you 12 500 in
commission every month without having to
do
anything yourself the maths impresses
you imagine what you could do with that
money
[Music]
you have to be able to recruit hundreds
you gotta recruit more people into that
team on a weekly basis recruiting
you need to become a great recruiter
period the bottom line you're told to
write a list of 100 names
friends family members people you
haven't spoken to in a while numbers on
your contact list
instagram followers anyone and everyone
reach out to
10 people a day for the rest of this
month
you know what i mean we should really
push it we should spread the word as
much as possible reach out to 100 people
that you know that you think could be
good for this industry you start
messaging your friends you start telling
your family members about this
opportunity you start posting more to
your social media pages you buy your
next month's supply of products
once more you're told that you must
invest in your business this is your
opportunity
and this is your time and get in your
vehicle
and drive you continue reading the
self-help material you attend the weekly
seminars calls events
your upline continues telling you that
anything is possible if you work hard at
it
if you stay positive and get rid of the
negative people who doubt you
your new life is going to cost you your
old one
you're showered with more stories about
others in the company who are living the
dream thanks to this opportunity i
introduced my own wife to the company
and she earns tens of thousands of
dollars now
there's no doubt in my mind i'm already
watching people make it work
i've already made about a thousand
dollars doing this in about three weeks
so it's working we have an incredible
upline of proof that this business
works
you've gotten a few rejections now your
friends weren't as open to the ideas you
had initially thought perhaps some chose
to buy some product off you but when it
came to recruiting you just couldn't get
them to cross that bridge
more team meetings seminars calls more
self-help motivations
no recruits yet it's because you haven't
worked hard enough you weren't thinking
positive enough your friends aren't
interested in joining it just means you
need new friends
they will resent you some people
because you're so successful
[Music]
and you must not let those people bother
you you're told to post more on your
socials even if it feels like you're
faking a lifestyle or faking your income
you're told that it will be enough to
attract
curious eyes hope and belief keep you
going
some friends have begun distancing
themselves from you or perhaps you've
distanced yourself from them
after all if they weren't willing to
join the company then they're just
negative influencers
at least that's what your upline tells
you whilst encouraging you to buy more
product
and continue investing in your business
sure you haven't made much money yet but
hope keeps you alive the company holds a
conference that year
a conference where countless
distributors across the world come to
celebrate the opportunity it's a
spectacle flashing lights performances
motivation and the dream is once more
sold to you
how many of you know that arbonne is
worth more than a ten thousand dollar
envelope
and this plexus is the best vehicle you
will ever
have in your lifetime to do that
a fresh wave of motivation overcomes you
this is your community
your family people with like-minded
goals opinions and interests
you with us together it's family
and nobody messes with the family the
cycle continues you reach out to more
people now finding anyone that seems
like they would need some cash
someone that you could sell the dream to
work harder stay positive
remove negative influences it's all on
you to make this happen
perhaps you finally recruit someone or a
few people and suddenly a little more
money comes in
it may not be much but it's the start
you tell yourself you're officially
there upline you're officially hosting
your own meetings telling them that they
have to work harder for the dream
encouraging them to buy more product to
invest in their business encouraging
them to stay positive to reach out to as
many people as possible
you need these recruits to stay on board
they're essential to the dream
but there it comes again that feeling
that something isn't quite right
something just feels off a look through
your social media profiles reveals a
lifestyle that you aren't really living
products from another company that you
don't really own
bank statements that reveal that not
much has changed over the last few years
a bookshelf worth of self-help content
old friends you haven't spoken to in a
while who you've either distanced
yourself from or cut out from your life
entirely
the people you hang out with now are
from the company you're a distributor
for
and how many of them are living the
dream you wonder why is it that we're
all faking it till we make it who are
the ones that are actually making it
here
these are dangerous thoughts you realize
any mention of these thoughts to your
upline and that spells trouble but yet
this feeling has been here from the
start
as though you were lied to about
something as though the truth of the
matter has been concealed from you
and you'd be right you see before you
joined this company there were some
critical details that you should have
understood about what you were getting
yourself
into stick with me now because it's
about time you find out exactly what
these details were
but before we continue a quick ad break
a month before starting this channel
there was one skill i needed to learn in
order to make videos like the one you're
watching right now
that skill was video editing and i'd
spent an entire month learning through
online classes how to edit videos now
little did i know that
learning that skill allowed me to create
a channel like this with an audience
like you guys
just by learning one skill which brings
me on to this video's sponsor skillshare
and i know
a lot of you have heard of skillshare
before but for those of you that don't
skillshare is
an awesome online learning community
with quite literally thousands
of high quality classes for those of you
that are looking to develop new skills
or
just hone your craft and i know because
i genuinely use skillshare myself
recently i've been taking gary
vaynerchuk's classes on marketing
through social media and standing out in
a saturated market
which i highly recommend you guys check
out it's really good but skillshare's
got classes on
video editing web design graphic design
marketing
all the way to mindfulness and
meditation and maybe you guys might have
a business idea that you really want to
execute on but you don't know how to
program well
now might be a good time to start and
skillshare is pretty cheap it comes at
the price of about three coffees a month
and they're constantly putting out new
classes
but thankfully i've got you guys covered
the first 1000 people to click the link
in the description and sign up to
skillshare do get their first
two months for free it's thanks to you
guys and sponsors like skillshare that
let me create videos full time
so if learning a new skill and having
access to thousands of classes whenever
you need it sounds like something you'd
be interested in then do click the link
down below in the description and be one
of the first 1000 to sign up but with
that being said
let's dive right back into the video
[Music]
soon though i looked into the history of
the company and what i found left me
shocked and actually
worried about my family it's a shame
that you're never doing it if you're
never working hard enough you're never
being enough
you need more and more more
multi-level marketing companies fall
under different names
different products different people but
the overarching structure remains the
same
these companies don't sell their
products via retailers but rather a
workforce of people who are paid a
commission on their sales sounds just
fine
so why the controversy let's start with
its pyramid-shaped recruiting model
mlms as they're often shortened to allow
their distributors to recruit other
distributors who are called their
downlines
uplines are able to earn a commission on
any sales that their downlines make
but remember these downlines are also
able to recruit their own members
so it's a pyramid scheme right we'll get
to that mlms have been around for a long
while
with routes that go as far back as the
1880s these companies have existed for
generations and many of their practices
remain the same
the promotion of self-help content and
concepts big conventions
the selling of a dream all of these
themes are prevalent in many of these
companies
some of the top mlm companies are well
known for their female target market
according to the direct selling
association 74
of those involved with mlm companies in
america are women
if you visit any stay at home mum's page
on facebook it won't take you long to
find someone promoting their mlm company
the mlm pitch appeals to those that are
struggling to make ends meet financially
or those who are young and naive enough
to be taken in by the grandeur of the
events and the barrage of self-help
messages
the controversy that surrounds these
companies is endless the federal trade
commission has already received
170 complaints against the company they
make you
feel guilty they will specifically
target your insecurities
an mlm's biggest weapon that they can
use against
you and that they do use against you is
shame
one infamous example in 2012 saw
billionaire investor and hedge fund
manager bill ackman
take a short position on the mlm company
herbalife
he called the company a flat out pyramid
scheme what are you accusing herbalife
of
being a pyramid scheme we believe we're
believe experiments game
which sparked a wall street rivalry
between himself and rival carl icahn
who started buying shares into herbalife
to counter blackmon's position
this is not an honest guy and this is
not a guy who keeps this word and it's
the guy who takes
takes advantage of little people and yet
despite ackman's confidence
he exited his short position in 2018
without success
so what's really going on here is the
dream real or one big lie
why all the self-help content and the
grand conventions
why aren't mlms illegal if they're
supposedly pyramid schemes
a pyramid scheme usually operates under
the following premise
there's a founder the founder tells a
select few people that for a certain
price they can join his amazing business
opportunity
it sounds great and they agree to buy in
these people are then encouraged by the
founder to recruit other people for a
buy-in to recoup their initial
investment
each new member of the scheme is
encouraged to recruit somebody new
and the money continues to be funneled
up the system but any mathematician can
see the colossal
problem with this model and why it's
made illegal for everyone to make money
in a pyramid scheme there needs to be an
endless supply of recruits
but that's impossible if the founder
recruited five members
and these five members recruited five
more members after 13 tiers you would
have exceeded the entire population of
the united states
and after 15 tears you exceed the entire
population of the planet
pyramid schemes are mathematically
designed to collapse
and when those on the bottom of the
pyramid start realizing that nobody is
making money and drop out of the scheme
the tears above lose their ability to
make money and suddenly each tier begins
collapsing once they lose their only
source of income
these schemes are disguised as many
things and come in different shapes and
sizes but their effects
can be devastating they place an
emphasis on recruiting
others and are riddled with promises of
high returns in short periods of time
and claims of easy money or passive
income it is only those in the top tiers
that make money
from a pyramid scheme and since most
people come in at the bottom tiers
the vast majority of those entering a
pyramid scheme will lose their money as
finding enough recruits to pay for their
initial investment gets harder and
harder
keep that in mind now let's look at
cults
to spot one can sometimes be difficult
because just like pyramid schemes they
hide in plain sight
disguised as many things but that of
which they actually are some red flags
on their own are not enough to draw
conclusions
but combined they create a mantle piece
for manipulation and indoctrination
they're designed to influence who you
are as a person step
by step until you've walked so many
steps that you're no longer what you
used to be and haven't even realized it
yet those red flags include
a high level of commitment from its
members and a seemingly unquestionable
loyalty towards its leader or anyone at
the top of the hierarchy
a feeling that you're working towards
some sort of bigger goal
mission or dream with the group your
plexus business
is an assignment from god to help you
build your faith
[Applause]
the promotion of an us versus them
mentality the idea that you are a
collective group
a family and those that oppose the
ideals of the group are an enemy and
must not be listened to you
with us together it's family
and nobody messes with the family anyone
who leaves the group
are shunned by others because of this
critical thinking is often abandoned by
the group members
you can't question what you're being
told to be negative or critical about
the group's ideologies is the equivalent
of betrayal
you cannot let logic control you
logic is is bad for us you're made to
feel dependent on the group
over time the group becomes your only
environment you don't see or speak to
your friends and family as much
and in some cases you'll be made to lose
any connections with your friends and
family unless they're a part of the
group too
it's a process designed to isolate you
from your past identity
turning you into a drone that is
entirely dependent on the group
and the hopeful mission and vision that
what you are doing is for the betterment
of the world
with both pyramid schemes and cults
there's an assumption that to fall for
it you must be a fool
or an idiot but that isn't true in most
cases an individual falls for these
schemes and groups because of their
circumstances
particularly when they are in a
vulnerable position the loss of a job
a loved one a lack of high quality
relationships a feeling of helplessness
with your life
these groups and schemes are designed to
use your emotions against you and
exploit you in some way or another
whether financially or emotionally
and that brings us back to mlms
[Music]
at its core multi-level marketing is a
strategy to market a product or service
without needing to worry about
advertising costs or paying employees on
a standard payroll
legally these companies are not pyramid
schemes
as we saw a standard pyramid scheme
makes its money solely off recruiting
mlms on the other hand revolve around
the selling of a product or service
and paid distributors a commission on
their sales therefore
it is possible to make money in an mlm
without recruiting someone else
it's through this loophole that mlm
companies can get away with being
legal pyramid schemes and that's a fair
enough conclusion but with each mlm
there is a fine line and an
all-important question that must be
asked
where is the majority of the revenue
coming from the actual selling of a
product to organic customers
or distributors buying product from the
very company they're working for
so they can remain as distributors and
what's encouraged more within your mlm
the recruiting aspect
or the sales the more recruiting is
pushed the more you should question your
position in that company and the facade
that's being laid out in front of you
and how real is the dream that you've
been sold the promise of financial
freedom that draws in so many
distributors year after year
what about the people that you hear
about who are making so much money from
the company
legally these companies are expected to
release income disclosures each year
a chart that details the average
earnings for distributors in the company
which does not include
expenses in every mlm company that i
have seen
the vast majority of distributors will
lose money whilst others will break even
or make minimum wage
it is the point one percent of those at
the top of the company that are making a
substantial income
they're the ones that are praised and
put up on stages at these events
so that a survivorship bias is spread
amongst other distributors so the dream
and the hope is not lost so that the
other 90
of those in the crowd don't realize that
most of them are not making money
that the dream they were sold is a lie
and what about the self-help content the
cult-like mentality that some of these
mlms promote
they're designed to keep you hooked in
to isolate you from any outside forces
that could persuade you from leaving
and if you feel as though you're failing
then it must be your fault after all
you didn't work hard enough you weren't
positive enough
that's why they indoctrinate you with so
much
self-help and guilt you into
always staying positive or else
everything bad that happens to you is
your fault because you didn't try hard
enough you didn't work hard enough
and you didn't stay positive enough
but is my assessment of these companies
too harsh
truth is i can't comment on every mlm in
existence
when multi-level marketing is just a
marketing strategy each company has to
be looked at on a case-by-case basis but
let me point out some key flaws in this
business model that i think you should
be aware of
there is no screening process there is
no interview to see how qualified you
are for the job
the barrier to entry is negligible as
long as you have enough money to buy the
starter pack or the membership fee
these companies end up with countless
inexperienced salespeople making money
solely through their commissions with no
sense of accountability
what could one possibly expect from such
a scenario especially when these people
are encouraged to recruit more and more
individuals not based on their
qualifications but on who they think are
in a vulnerable enough state to buy into
the dream
i targeted people like me
mums young mums people maternity leave
as it got towards christmas i actually
targeted people
that couldn't afford to pay for
christmas there is no grasp on supply
and demand
anyone can join and start selling the
product and at some point the market for
that product will reach its limit but
the supply will continue to grow
resulting with a bunch of distributors
competing over the same market
spreading the profits thinner and
thinner between each other and what
about the actual products
the odds are usually stacked up against
distributors especially when they're
selling products that have prices marked
up three times higher than the standard
retail price
and being your own boss it's another
facade you're simply an independent
contractor for the company
you have no control over the products
nor the commission structure
i can't comment on all mlms but i can
say that if you are watching this and
feel as though you want to join one then
do your due diligence
if you were sold a dream and quick money
tread carefully
if you see that the majority of the
money is being made through recruiting
tread carefully if a cult-like mentality
is pushed and you're made to distance
yourself from friends and family or are
made to feel guilty for not succeeding
because you didn't work hard enough
tread carefully the pursuit of financial
freedom
or a better life and not uncommon dreams
they're shared by many
including myself but if someone or
something comes promising you that goal
that dream that vision
dangling it in front of you like a
carrot on a stick disguised as an
opportunity
then it's best you take a moment to
pause think rationally
and remember that if it sounds too good
to be true
it probably is
hello my friends and before you click
off the video i just wanted to say
thank you so much for watching to the
end i've been wanting to do a video on
mlms for a while now since the fake guru
video
so it's good to finally cover that
industry if you're new to the channel
hi my name is james jenny and i like to
make documentary style videos
on topics surrounding business finance
and life in general so if that sounds
like something you'd be interested in do
hit the subscribe button and of course
if you like this
video do hit the like button because it
does help it get pushed by the youtube
algorithm and remember if you'd like to
sign up to skillshare and get two months
free click the link in the description
but with all of that being said my
friends i hope you have a wonderful rest
of the day
as always hand to head salute
to many days to come
scouring facebook groups instagram posts
finding anyone that seems like
[Music]
it is only those in the top tiers that
make money
wow okay
[Music]
through the sunrise i will thrive
getting out alive
getting out alive
when you find that open
[Music]
them